well folks we are not going to be
getting those secret service text
messages many of you i know have been
following this story this week anxiously
awaiting yesterday tuesday when
supposedly
the text messages deleted by the secret
service
after they were told don't delete these
text messages preserve records
they are not going to be able to able to
turn them over to the january 6th
committee investigating the trump riots
this is a really really big deal this
really actually should be a major
scandal and i don't know if it's going
to become one as it seems even the
secret service under trump which we
suspected we talked about it at the time
even the secret service under trump
supposedly
in theory apolitical uh has fallen fell
under the thumb of wacky trumpism so
let's reset the story
the january 6th committee
subpoenaed some u.s secret service
records
um a government watchdog found believed
that the agency had erased important
text messages from january 5th and
january 6 2021
the secret service uh was told even if
these were deleted you have to recover
them and there were conflicting and
changing explanations as to why the
secret service didn't have them first it
was something related to
changes to the um pieces of equipment
elements of technology that they were
using they did a phone migration well it
turns out that that phone migration
started after the request for these text
messages so it's all increasingly
more and more fishy and now we learn
you're not gonna get the text messages
uh washington post report secret service
cannot
okay cannot recover texts no new details
for the january sixth committee the u s
secret service has determined it has no
new text messages to provide congress
relevant to its january 6th
investigation and that any other texts
its agents exchanged around the time of
the trump riots were purged purged also
the national archives sought more
information on the potential
unauthorized deletion
of agency text messages the u.s
government's chief record keeper asked
secret service to report back within 30
days about the deletion of records
including describing what was purged and
the circumstances of how the
documentation was lost it's just gone
guys and yes it's as suspicious as such
as a a situation as it sounds
it is amazing what you are unable to do
when you're determined not to do
something and i'm reminded of donald
trump and his tax records donald trump
was obviously from day one determined
never to publish his private tax records
it was abundantly clear and so first it
was well i'm under ardet as he liked to
say from the irs and once the audits are
complete then but wait sir which years
are under audit it could give us
something it can't be that every year of
recent taxes is well i'm under audit i'm
under audit and my lawyers say don't do
it oh okay so then after well no and
well now it's re-election it's four
years later you're not still being
audited for those same years are you
well i don't know the american people
don't care about that he was determined
not to publish his tax returns
and he didn't publish them the secret
service here was clearly determined not
to recover
or provide or publicize or deliver these
text messages and that's exactly what
they're doing so now we have at least
a reasonable suspicion that secret
service was involved complicit
indifferent to what was going on on
january 6th now let's add to that
add to our understanding
this
seemingly strange data point mike pence
didn't want to get in the car with
secret service on that day
that's weird but we didn't really know
what to make of it at least not
initially it kind of doesn't make sense
why wouldn't the if secret service comes
to the vice president and says uh mr
vice president sir
we've got to get you out of here it's
not safe
and pence goes i'm not going i'm not
getting in a car with you guys
that is strange but it was sort of out
of context initially
do we now have a little bit more of the
picture where secret service here
seemingly for what appear to be
political reasons i mean there's been no
other explanation given the explanations
about technological reasons shifted oh
it was a data migration it was new
devices it was these different things
that none of it makes sense
but what now does make some sense
is the idea that pence knew
what we are increasingly aware of which
is that even the secret service
was
not infiltrated but taken over
by trump loyalists if you think back to
when trump was in the hospital with
covid
and on day two
trump insisted on going out for this joy
ride with his mask on
to wave to people around walter reed
hospital and we all said that's hugely
irresponsible he's stuffing a bunch of
seeds he's he's very sick and he's
stuffing secret service agents into the
vehicle and we heard anecdotally oh some
of the secret service agents didn't like
it they were exposed high rate of covet
among them
maybe most of them are actually okay
with it i mean at the end of the day if
it was trump loyalists hand-picked even
within secret service to be around maybe
they thought it was cool that he was
going around and saying hi to the people
so
that's increasingly the picture we have
of secret service under trump now
separately
what's going on with merrick garland
merrick garland is attorney general
and so far
he's shown no willingness willingness to
really go after high-level people
potentially involved with criminality
related to january 6 related to the
post-election period what's going on at
doj we don't know
this
is investigation worthy the secret
service should be investigated over
these deleted texts by the highest level
and that would be as a federal agency
that would be by the department of
justice
is that going to happen
is there any evidence merit garland is
willing to do that it's an
extraordinarily suspicious timeline
congress tells the secret service
preserve the documents from january 5
and 6 on january 16th it had only been
10 days january 16th 2021 congress says
keep the documents and then again they
say that on january 25th and then two
days later
this is now two weeks after being told
keep the records
the secret service starts a phone
migration
and all of a sudden it's all gone and we
can't get any of it this is major news
this should be a major scandal we will
see where it goes
we have
more reason to believe
that the most serious investigation of
the attempts to steal the 2020 election
are happening in georgia
the fake electors
have now been subpoenaed in georgia and
we're going to talk about it this is
correct this is a good thing but to
contextualize
i've continued to insist
that the most likely
orange or origin
of
charges high-level criminal charges
against the top people in the trump
administration
are most likely to come
from the georgia investigation that's
the one where donald trump famously said
on the phone i need eleven hundred and
seven eleven thousand seven hundred and
eighty votes give me a break that's the
one where lindsey graham the senator
from south carolina called to see well
what could be done there that's the one
that really seems most obviously
criminal and most provably criminal and
that georgia investigation continues to
signal that it is the most likely place
where charges may stem nbc news
reporting georgia fake electors hit with
subpoenas in criminal probe this move
indicates the district attorney is
homing in on potential charges related
to the alleged plot by trump's team to
overturn the 2020 election nearly a
dozen of georgia's fake electors
revealed tuesday they've been subpoenaed
to appear before the fulton county
special grand jury hearing evidence in
the criminal investigation into 2020
interference by trump and his allies the
revelation came in a court filing where
attorneys for 11 of the state's 16 false
presidential electors tried to quash
subpoenas calling them unreasonable and
oppressive
the attorneys also argued that fulton
county d.a fannie willis's office
initially said their clients were
witnesses not subjects or targets and
that they agreed to voluntary interviews
although it appears as though that has
changed
this is a very good sign it seems fanny
willis is taking this extraordinarily
seriously it appears that on august 2nd
unless something changes senator lindsey
graham is going to have to appear and
testify not as a target that we know but
this is a brazen and direct attempt to
subvert the will of the people to
subvert democracy it was authoritarian
and it was fascistic the plot was and
this happened in multiple states what do
david fake electors what do you mean
some is it a fake person like it's a
mannequin what do you mean now here's
what i mean
joe biden won georgia
and because joe biden won georgia
georgia's electoral votes go to joe
biden when you count and try to get to
270 votes which is what you need to
become president
georgia and all states won by joe biden
say put ours
in the biden column and then you add
them up and if you get to 270 you become
president the scam that among others
trump was running in georgia and other
states was
just
put together a slate of republican
electors have them all sign oh we the
dually undersigned are indeed the
electors and we cast our electoral votes
for donald trump even though trump
didn't win the state that was the idea
and it's being investigated in a serious
manner in uh wisconsin it's being
investigated in a serious manner in
arizona maybe in other states as well i
don't have the full list in front of me
and in georgia and in georgia
fannie willis wants to know
who organized you this was a thing where
there was an elector a fake elector in
arizona confronted by a reporter
and he said was this part of like a big
plan
and the fake elector was evasive and
didn't really say anything he was like
no i just showed up
well how did you know
where to go and when to show up you
might say well i believe trump won but
if you want to show up and try to sign
fake elector forms someone clearly told
you where to go and when to go if i
wanted to be a fake elector i wouldn't
just go to the dmv on tuesday at 10 i
would someone would tell me this is
where we're meeting to sign papers who
was that and the guy refused to answer
and eventually walked away so fannie
willis is taking this seriously in
georgia the electors have been
subpoenaed they are going to have to
appear unless something changes and
maybe we will get answers as to how high
up was the organization of these fake
electors very important
huge
this is one of the things where we spoke
to a lawyer
uh involved in this in wisconsin last
week
and he agreed
thankfully
a number of safeguards prevented these
alternate electors from being considered
legitimate and valid
but in theory if you had a motivated
governor and the right things in place
they could say yeah well we don't
believe biden won we believe trump won
and so we're certifying the republican
electors instead and then you would have
a hellish situation on your hands so we
are going to follow this closely we'll
tell you when they'll be testifying and
what is likely to come of it in the
meantime find me on twitter at deepakman
and remember that we have the next david
pakman show viewer town hall coming up
on tuesday
july 26th
at 6 pm eastern
it will stream exclusively on our second
youtube channel pacman live and we'll be
taking questions from everybody i hope
you'll participate more on that later
this week
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is an audience
supported program you can sign up for
membership at joinpackman.com
you can use the coupon code big voting
22 for a discount now why would you sign
up well not only are you supporting our
work which i hope you think is at least
slightly worth doing you also get a
daily extra program called the bonus
show
and you get a commercial free audio and
video feed of the show wherein the daily
show is made available to you with no
commercials five to six hours earlier
than when it goes live to everybody else
pretty good perks you also get priority
handling
for our viewer town halls the next of
which is coming up on july 26th hey i'm
going to show you some amazing stuff
fox news had to spend the day yesterday
covering this historic record-breaking
heat wave in the united states
in europe they had to do it they had to
cover the story because it was such a
major story
without talking about climate change and
the fact that for decades now we are
seeing more and more higher high
temperatures record high temperatures
extreme heat and extreme cold and
extreme weather events all of which a
comprehensive climate change model uh
would predict and
expect
this is just wild wild stuff so let's
start with some of the images
that appeared on fox news and they don't
mention climate change they talk about
it's hot but they don't talk about the
relationship to climate change excess
heat
parts of us face warnings and advisories
major story on fox news no mention of
climate change
drought monitor exceptional drought arid
conditions carry tinderbox effect of
course very high fire risk another
aspect of climate change and how climate
change can influence
um
it can influence the amount of land you
have that is potentially useful for uh
growing food when these fires run
through okay we've talked about it
before drought monitor
uh dallas triple digit temperatures
weather conditions forecast to continue
insane temperatures in dallas dallas
including highs of 109 and 108 this week
all of these stories didn't mention
climate change once now i know it's fox
news i know it's fox news but still it
is notable that they go out of their way
not to talk about climate change let's
look at a segment this is brett bayer
from fox news breaking tonight much of
europe is experiencing record
temperatures as a brutal heat wave rolls
through the continent britain shattered
its all-time record with a reading of
104.4 degrees fahrenheit of course at
heathrow airport london's mayor says the
temperatures are causing a huge surge in
the number of fires in the city one
grass fire in wenington required more
than 100 firefighters to come to that
scene ferocious wildfires continue in
south and southwestern france more than
2 thousand firefighters have been
deployed there tens of thousands of
people have been evacuated nearly 750
health-related deaths have already been
reported in spain and neighboring
portugal more than 30 forest fires
around spain have forced thousands of
evacuations
many parts of this country also dealing
with record heat robert ray of fox
weather has specifics from round rock
texas which can't be cool
by the way remember fox weather is the
new fox news weather channel that's
that's a whole other thing where um it's
the
it it's the version i mean listen i it's
they do some weather but it's the way to
now make weather political and we've
talked about that before as well let's
continue today good evening robert
good evening brett i found a little
shade here in the lone star state and i
will say over 100 million people across
the u.s are experiencing excessive heat
warnings not a good situation 60 million
of those people brett are in the lower
mississippi valley the southern plains
and here in texas
dallas uh the big d expected to be about
110 soon oklahoma city actually did hit
110 degrees it's the first time since
august of 2011 and the state capital of
austin about 110 san antonio el paso
even over to shreveport louisiana right
and you see that big orange ball that is
the sun that is the sun folks do not be
confused that orange ball is indeed the
sun now a re
a reasonable question would be
is there anything systemic going on that
might be leading to us doing this every
summer every summer saying record high
record high never seen before now you
might come back and say but david i
thought weather wasn't climate and you
were correct an individual weather event
is not
the same thing as climate a single
stronger than usual unseasonably late
hurricane
doesn't really tell us anything about
what's happening with the climate but
multiple decades of higher high
temperatures
lower low temperatures unseasonably warm
unseasonably cold
stronger and more and stronger
hurricanes during hurricane season all
of those things not just one day
start to tell us about the climate of a
place and whether the climate is
changing so a weather event would be oh
a crazy heat wave in new york city one
time
the change of climate would be
every summer the average temperature in
new york city as well as the number of
days that reach triple digits goes up
and you observe that over multiple
decades now we're talking about a change
to the climate of a place that goes
beyond an individual event it's sort of
like the same thing i talked about it
was either last week or the week before
why is it that anecdotal evidence is bad
well it's it's not so much that
anecdotal evidence is bad when it's
comprehensively collected
systematized and used to ascertain
patterns but then it's no longer
anecdotal then it's how we gather data
individual anecdotes insufficient
anecdotes out of context anecdotes are
what aren't useful so
uh that's what's going on this is the
exact pattern that is predicted by
climatologists erratic weather
unseasonable weather records of
different kinds stronger storms drought
etc etc that's exactly what's happening
and fox news because it's fox news
doing everything they can
not to talk about climate until night
time and i won't even get into this but
then at night they started ridiculing
the climate uh change believers the
people that accept science with stuff
like
liberals shocked that it's hot in the
summer
which of course
kind of misses the point we'll keep
talking about it the heat wave will
continue and we'll actually have more
about this on the bonus show
if i told you
folks in my audience
donald trump called a wisconsin official
to try to overturn the election results
that would not be the most surprising
headline right you would say well we
know he called georgia and we know he
was doing funny business with arizona
it's not really surprising that he
called wisconsin as well sure
what is surprising is trump called the
wisconsin official last week to try to
overturn the results this is not a
repeat it's july of 2022 the election
was in november of 2020. donald trump
called the wisconsin official last week
to continue trying to overturn the
election and when the official was not
into trump's requests he went on truth
said
truth central truth social he went on
truth social
and started calling the guy a rhino all
right so let's look at this this is
assembly speaker robin vos who was
interviewed and says
trump called me last week
to try to
overturn and change the results in
wisconsin
look at this
when's the last time you talked to the
former president president trump uh
within the last week in the last week
yeah before after he tweeted about that
before and what was that conversation
like you know it's one of those that
it's very consistent he makes his case
which i respect um he would like us to
do something different in wisconsin i
explained that it's not allowed under
the constitution he has a different
opinion then he put the tweet out so
listen to that listen he calls me he
tells me what he wants me to do which i
respect and then i explain to him it's
unconstitutional
why would you respect
trump
trying to strong-arm you into doing
something that's unconstitutional that
that's not worthy of respect and i guess
robin vos is you know trying to mince
words here a little bit what is to be
respected about a former president
demanding unconstitutional action and
case in point
i believe robin vos told trump on the
phone yeah we can't do that because then
trump took to truth social and attacked
robin boss saying quote looks like
speaker robin vos a long time
professional rhino always looking to
guard his flank will be doing nothing
about the amazing wisconsin supreme
court decision stating loud and clear
that the impossible to control ballot
unlock boxes in the state are illegal
what a waste of a brilliant and
courageous decision by wisconsin's
highest court the democrats would like
to sincerely thank robin and all of his
fellow rhinos for letting them get away
with murder
a rigged and stolen election now i want
to remind people in the audience who may
have forgotten or maybe you don't know
there is no such thing as
decertification
donald trump's goal
is or donald trump's belief maybe
is that if there is a court ruling that
says oh these ballot boxes were
improperly used that you can decertify
the election now first of all you can't
because those very boxes had a mix of
biden and trump ballots in them and
there is absolutely no way to even
demonstrate that those specific boxes
favored one candidate or heard another
but we're already in beyond fantasy
because there's no such process as
decertification stephen bannon has been
talking about this for a year
he'll casually say on his show
oh yeah we're moving to decertify
arizona oh wow that geez that sounds
pretty serious there is no such process
as decertification like what does trump
think will happen a state will say
we decertify biden as the winner
and then biden's kicked out of the white
house and trump is ushered in
there is no such process the election
ended
uh 20 months ago
biden was sworn in
18 months ago and there are very few
ways in which biden leaves early and in
none of those situations does trump
become the president if joe biden dies
kamala harris becomes president they
don't go back and say uh sir trump come
back doesn't happen number two joe biden
resigns kamala harris becomes president
not donald trump number three congress
uh impeaches and convicts joe biden
forcing him out of office kamala becomes
president not donald trump 25th
amendment is used if the cabinet
believes the president cannot carry out
their duties they can invoke the 25th
amendment biden's removed kamala harris
becomes president of the united states
not donald trump so there is no such
problem think about the layers
there's no evidence that a
desertification should take place in any
state
even if there was evidence there is no
process for decertification doesn't
exist
and even if
you were able to through a process that
exists like resignation
impeachment death of a president 25th a
minute remove the president
it doesn't go to donald trump it goes to
the vice president so it is three or
four layers removed from reality last
week
trump tried to get the wisconsin results
overturned
it's crazy check out the clip on our
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com david
pakman show electric vehicles
increasingly a target of the
anti-everything right wing as many of
you know i am four electric vehicles i
have an electric vehicle i think they're
great in many ways nothing is perfect
everything has pros and cons i think
that the reality of electric vehicles is
good enough i don't feel like anything
needs to be exaggerated about them but
also a lot of the claims made about
electric vehicles that are negative
claims are false and i'm going to play
for you such an example on fox news
yesterday judge jeanine pirro this is an
image of geraldo rivera but he's on a
program with judge jeanine pirro she
delivered
an unhinged tirade about electric
vehicles that ends up with her yelling
what if you live in middle america who
gives a damn about what's happening in
new york city i mean completely
unintelligible listen to the specific
claims she makes and we'll talk about
them one by one
i submit respectfully that uh if they
want to lead by example then they've got
to bite the bullet
okay this is what i think
i think when joe biden came out and he
told those mom-and-pop gas stations to
lower the prices and do it now they all
got scared of joe and they said we
better lower the price of gas look
that's all hogwash what this guy is
doing right now is he's taking credit
for something that he didn't do okay and
now they're if he declares this
emergency he's going to everybody's
going to say oh my gosh what are we
going to do there's not going to be any
gas and even though he's taking credit
for more gas
they've got to buy now an electric
vehicle
okay so
so before she even gets into electric
vehicles this is the same old story
biden gets all of the blame for the
run-up of gas prices and none of the
credit for the decline now i think he
has barely anything to do with both and
and i said that under trump i said it
under obama i said it under bush
presidents have very little to do with
gas prices but on fox they blame biden
for the increase and they don't give him
credit but then now she says really the
switcheroo is they want to get you on
electric vehicles an electric vehicle
the average one costs sixty-four
thousand dollars the average car costs
forty six thousand dollars the average
american doesn't have a new car so the
average american and when pete buddha
judge says look you may pay a little
more on your car payment the average
american doesn't have a car payment okay
so first of all
the
wow
if you
were to even start if americans don't
have car payments then it's not really
even relevant but the important thing
here is when she talks about the average
price of electric vehicles the number
she states is outdated actually average
price of electric vehicle 2022
um
it's down to 54 000 so
let's actually think that through
janine says
nobody can afford electric vehicles okay
average electric vehicle cost 64k
and average non-electric vehicle new
costs 46k okay that's a difference of 18
000
the real average price of an electric
vehicle in 2022 is 54 000 now it's still
more right 54 000 versus 46 000 but
there's a 70 up to a 7 500 federal
credit for people who buy electric
vehicles so all of a sudden your 8 000
difference becomes much smaller and then
you have the fact that on average it
costs one third of what it costs in a
gas vehicle to go one mile with an
electric vehicle so janine is just wrong
the cars aren't cheap for sure
but when you consider the gas savings
and the credit
it's actually not as big of a difference
anymore now not everybody gets new cars
that's absolutely true let's continue
the average american is driving a car
that he or she has had for a long time
and they're not making payments the car
is paid for it's old they're just
surviving and deciding if they have
enough gas to go to work and to buy the
food that they need and the sad part of
all this is that they don't understand
america they don't understand what's
going on in america when they say oh
just buy an electric vehicle or oh the
government should should get electric
vehicles if we don't have the
infrastructure for electric vehicles we
can in part because the government
hasn't invested enough in that
infrastructure right i mean the
infrastructure will follow demand we are
already seeing that in areas where you
see more electrical vehicle sales you
see more companies enter the market and
say we're gonna do charging stations
we're gonna do portable charging we're
gonna do uh a device that you can keep
in your trunk with a fully charged
battery to charge right out of it and
then you just swing by and you get one
that's already charged and leave yours
all of these things are they talk about
the market allow the market to function
i'm not going to tell you who it is but
the guy that i buy some of my cars from
he says to me janine i'm buying one he
said i don't even like it i don't want
to drive it i can't drive it anywhere
but around town
this is all let me finish this is all
make-believe nonsense where america is
not supporting these green lunatics i
was driving into work today went to
starbucks
charging 10 charging stations in the
starbucks yep right
right it's growing the infrastructure
what if you're an american living in
middle america
who gives a damn about what's going on
in new york city next to the starbucks
so the other thing that they often will
talk about with middle america is
there's no infrastructure you don't have
places to charge most people don't need
to charge anywhere other than home this
is the other
uh the the um anti-electric vehicle
uh or i don't want to call it an
industry the up opponents of electric
vehicles will often say these vehicles
just don't have long enough ranges
where you can count on
going and coming back from work even in
many cases even in middle america that's
an even bigger issue this is completely
untrue the median electric vehicle has
gone from being able to drive 68 miles
without a charge in 2011
to 234 miles right now that's the median
vehicle and there's ones with much
longer ranges
very few people even in middle america
have a commute that would make that
median range a problem let's be
conservative your goal is i want to go
to work and back
and i don't want to be cutting it close
i want 20
battery remaining when i get home
with the median electric vehicle 234
mile range you can do a 94 mile commute
now i don't mean 94 miles round trip i
mean you can go 94 miles to work
come back 94 miles and still have 20
percent battery left over you get the
gas savings you can get the federal
federal uh credit for the vehicle
and you don't have to charge anywhere
but at home in addition to that many
electric uh um companies
now give you rebates if you charge
during off-peak hours i just set up my
vehicle now by charging after
i think it's 9 p.m
um by charging only after 9 p.m i get
something like uh you know 5 cents per
kilowatt hour back and i get a check
every month uh it
they they are lying okay these are these
are simply not issues the cost of the
vehicles sure it's coming down the range
of the vehicles it's increasing the cost
of the electricity it's a fraction of
what gas cost and of course we could
have instead of subsidized gasoline
we could get rid of those subsidies let
the cost of gas really reflect the total
cost including the environmental cost
which we don't we don't have accurate
gas prices in the united states
and further subsidize the electric
vehicles so janine is completely
unhinged attacking everything that is
good if janine is against it you should
consider whether it's something we
should be very happy about
they are now officially moving on to gay
marriage we
said as we approached and learned about
and then got beyond the supreme court
decision overturning roe v wade that
they are not ending with overturning roe
v wade and why would they you don't get
your biggest win and then say now we
retire we don't want anything else
clarence thomas in his opinion and
others have said we've got to go on to
gay marriage we've got to go on to
gay adoption let's ban abortion outright
all of these different things and ted
cruz is now moving on and he is one of
many who are now focusing on this ted
cruz on his podcast is now saying
the issue of gay marriage
should also be left to states now what
does that mean
that means
states should be able to ban gay
marriage that's what you that's what you
mean when you say it should be decided
by the states listen to ted cruz
so berger fell
like roe versus wade ignored two
centuries of our nation's history
marriage was always an issue
that was left to the states you know
burger fell the court said no we know
better than you guys do and now every
state must
uh
must sanction and permit gay marriage
um i think that decision was clearly
wrong when it was decided
um
it was the court overreaching
imagine that applied to interracial
marriage listen
it's not that i'm against interracial
marriage it's that the supreme court
cannot decide that for the states states
must be allowed to determine do they
want to allow interracial marriages or
not that's the right way to do it and if
you extrapolate out from this idea of
leave everything to the states black
folks might still be enslaved in some
states in the south i mean maybe not
today but certainly into the early 1900s
that's for damn sure
civil rights and liberties are not
states rights issues they are guaranteed
by the constitution you don't put rights
up to a vote
at this point most americans recognize
that when you tell
one person
that they are able to get married and
someone else that they can't marry the
person that they love
you are deprying you you are depriving
them of something that most americans
now recognize is a right you just you
can marry the person that you love we're
not talking about marrying horses we're
not talking about marrying vehicles
we're talking about two people
entering into a contract that they want
to enter into you just don't put that up
to a vote and if you said to them by the
way
well let states regulate guns however
they want
they would say no no no no no we need
the supreme court to tell states you
can't do that because of the second
amendment and in fact the supreme court
recently did do that with a case that
got to the supreme court related to guns
so this is obviously their next target
they're not hiding it they're being
clear they won't stop here and they're
going to keep going and this is as as
demoralizing as it has been to see what
happened with roe v wade
if we now say we're bailing out on the
political system it will go to the next
thing it will go to gay marriage or
whatever else because they're they're uh
inspired they're activated they're fired
up now
uh so it puts 2022
really in focus as i would argue the
most important midterm election i've
covered during the time i've been doing
the show if you disagree with me let me
know let me put it a different way
has there been a more important midterm
election
i would even say
since 1994 when gingrich and that wacky
republican coalition took power tell me
i want to know has there been a more
important midterm than the one that is
forthcoming
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
hey so some of you might find this
interesting i've gotten a handful of
emails from from people saying david i
was loving those interviews of trumpest
candidates that you were doing over the
last few months but you haven't done one
for a while what's going on well it's
because they keep canceling on us they
something is going on and i'll tell you
what i believe it is where the trump is
candidates they agree to be on the show
we schedule it
it's an hour before the show
and then they cancel and then they say
oh
and i'll tell you what i think is going
on so as a reminder we did a bunch of
these republican candidate interviews of
republicans endorsed by donald trump we
interviewed john gibbs that one was wild
it got almost half a million views i
can't imagine it was particularly good
for the john gibbs campaign we did one
with darlene swaffer she's the one who
could not or refused to give a straight
answer to the question who is the
president of the united states and we
did some others and none of them really
went that well for the candidates but
people asked for more and so we had more
scheduled i think four or five different
ones but something
has happened between the time when they
agree and the time when we are ready to
do the interview they say yes i'll do it
we get it on the schedule and invariably
a few minutes to an hour to a couple of
hours before the interview they cancel
sometimes it's a no-call no show
sometimes it's oh something came up oh
we have a conflict all right well let's
reschedule yeah we'll get back to you
about rescheduling and then they never
do
and it's quite a list now now i'm not
going to name names because
it's in a it seems inappropriate to name
names and also of the list of five or so
some of them might really have had a
conflict and i don't want to like pick
and single out the wrong person
but obviously something is going on now
our colleague john who's been scheduling
these and dealing with the schedulers
thinks the explanation is very simple
oftentimes either the candidate
themselves or if they have a publicist
or a communications person they get
excited that someone wants to talk to
them and they go yeah i'll do it that
sounds good
they don't research the show
and then they go to the channel and they
see john gibbs making a fool out of
himself and half a million views or
darlene swaffer becoming memed on
twitter with a hundred thousand views on
a stupid little twitter clip that we put
together because she can't say who the
president of the united states is and
then they say i'm gonna bail out here so
we're available to chat
i want to learn about their ideas i want
to learn about the whole thing
and i also think i should mention like i
kind of get it in a way
doing this show isn't going to help them
you know to to win imagine that you're
running in the third district in
michigan or whatever right
to win you need to convince
not just all voters in that third
district of michigan because a lot of
them are not going to consider voting
for a lunatic trumpist you need to
convince the low information voters in
the third district of michigan
and they're mostly not in my audience
right i mean this is a show with a
mostly progressive audience yes some
center-right and right-wingers but most
of them don't live in the third district
of michigan or whatever the case may be
so i get it like at best doing an
interview on this show
it does nothing bad and gets you a
little bit of attention generally but
it's not the people that ultimately are
going to put you in office
and worst case it gets memed and it
hurts you so i can't say i blame them
but i wanted to put everybody on notice
with peace and love peace and love we're
doing what we can to get more of these
people on the show
most of them just decline and even the
ones that agree
i think we now have four in a row
who just bail
they just bail they end up not wanting
to do it if you want to see a sign of
how bad things are
in parts of the country
the first openly gay mayor of an
oklahoma town has resigned because of
threats to his security and harassment
now i want to mention
openly gay is not a term i usually use
because i i agree when you say openly
gay you're sort of saying like
there's shame around being gay
and so we have this category secretly
gay and openly gay like i i understand
that but the point here is
we're talking about someone
who acknowledges publicly as part of
their public presence that they're gay
and this is the first such mayor in
oklahoma and it's relevant to the story
but don't come after me about openly gay
i get it the first openly gay mayor of a
small town in oklahoma said he's
resigning after an increase in threats
to his safety
the village mayor adam graham who took
on the role in may said in the last
month he's been followed home from
meetings threatened while walking my dog
harassed at starbucks and have had my
tires slashed
he says since 2018 i fought against
ageism racism and homophobia at every
step unfortunately certain elements of
the population have recently become
emboldened to pursue threats and attacks
bordering on violence
the threats from the past month resulted
from an incident two months ago where i
stood up against nichols hill police
targeting the village residents
unfortunately these malicious bad faith
attacks are escalating and i no longer
feel safe to serve in my capacity as
mayor it is with a heavy heart i tender
my resignation sickening country and you
know what i can't blame him and yet in a
sense the terrorists win when this
happened right
you terrorize the gay mayor out of
office
and then you perpetuate that probably
the person who replaces him is going to
be heterosexual and you perpetuate the
homophobia they get a win it's not a
criticism
of the individual i get it i understand
why he's doing it
but at the same time this is sort of
like how they win so a very sad story
and this is not i'm not even this is not
whatever country you'd imagine this
happens in
this is the united states in 2022 and
the openly gay mayor
is afraid essentially for his safety
because of the level of harassment
people following him stalking etc
because he's gay
what else can you say extraordinarily
sad
a follow-up to a story from last week
this is pretty interesting
um
jesse lee peterson
caused a car accident across the street
from his
christian young men's counseling center
when being um asked questions by someone
on the street and dr rashad richie
covered it he also covered my coverage
of jessie lee peterson i'll give you the
back story jesse lee peterson is this
very outspoken
pro-trump black conservative pastor
and he's very homophobic he has spent
his career talking about sin and
being gay is bad and all these different
things and now
numerous individuals have come forward
saying they were in gay relationships
with jessie lee peterson that they were
um accosted for lack of a better term by
jessie lee peterson and i told my story
last week of how when i was in a studio
jessie lee peterson was very handsy with
me i didn't make much of it and it
wasn't sexual harassment or whatever
well dr rashad ritchie covered this
he mentions my coverage of jesse lee
peterson and he has the video of this
car accident that was caused by jessie
lee looking like he's going to step out
in front of fast-moving traffic to try
to get away from these questions check
this out follow up not only is anti lgbt
pastor jesse lee peterson gay
he's a predator
he may have even hit on david pakman
and he ran away
and caused an accident when someone
confronted him here's video
hey jesse peterson
martin francis here
how are you
so this is the post office right across
the street from his uh studio which i
visited
so i'm the first man in your whole
career
i am the first man in your whole career
that you have run from
like the chicken song that you play
you are running from me
so now jesse lee's
approaching a crosswalk sometimes
traffic gets going pretty fast here and
he looks like he's just gonna step right
into it car slams on its brakes car
behind it slams into that car
you're running from your from your uh
what you've been doing for 31
[Music]
and years lee doesn't even react to the
car wreck he causes
jesse's so upset that he uh tried to
cross the street before he should have
and caused these cars to stop and bash
and back and that's pretty serious
damage
so
[Music]
that's because um what a situation i now
have
video proof more so than
before tell me about you sleeping with
your brother's wife so quite a scene
there folks uh jessie lee peterson quite
literally causing an accident out on the
road as he uh stepped in now i want to
mention a couple of different things
about this story
number one
after i said last week
that
jessie was just very touchy with me
um uh
i'm so you know just that was my
personal experience i got a bunch of
emails from people saying
david don't you think he realized that
you're that you're gay and that you're
open to a relationship with him or
whatever okay i'm not gay and also he
wasn't
publicly acknowledging that he was gay
at the time either so that's like a
really strange thing to send me number
two some people wrote to me saying david
why are you outing jesse lee peterson
jesse lee peterson has not acknowledged
that he is gay so you're doing something
wrong no i i have not outed jessely
peterson i'm re reporting on stories
written about him that's what i'm doing
so the people writing to me and saying
even talking about it is wrong as if i'm
the one asserting that he's gay i have
no personal knowledge of that we're
talking about widely reported
uh claims
and number three would i go back on his
show sure yeah absolutely i would love
to go on his show and talk about this
why did he why did he feel as though
he couldn't just be who he was
uh that's terribly sad and i would want
to revisit my conversation with him
where he said he was celibate
um there's a lot i would want to talk to
him about so absolutely i would appear
on his show again we have a voicemail
number that number is 2192 david p
here's a caller who is skeptical that
gavin newsom really has what it takes to
be president take a listen to this
hey david so i want to ask you a
question about gavin newsom so me and a
friend were talking about gavin newsom
potentially running for president in
2024 and he's a republican he was
laughing a little bit he was like the
state of california doesn't even like
newsom he almost got um
recalled and
now all of a sudden you guys are pushing
him possibly for president he's gonna
get crushed blah blah blah i mean
what do you think about
his analysis of gavin newsom and
i know you've talked about the whole
recall thing but um yeah the analysis is
is very much wrong so
gavin newsom isn't well liked in
california okay well let's look at the
numbers in 2018 gavin newsom won
62 to 38 in california okay that's a
pretty major win and in 2020
uh let's see
what what did biden even win with
in 2020 biden got
basically the same yeah so almost
identical numbers califor biden and
newsom both won with very similar
numbers low 60s the recall election even
in the recall which is
sort of the odds are stacked against you
in a recall because the recall is
brought by period people that don't like
you so by by definition recalls often
have low turnout
skewed to the group that wants the
official removed
he also got 62 percent of the vote in
the recall
so i think gavin newsom's numbers are
absolutely fine i don't see an issue at
all does that mean that he would win an
election a national election for the
presidency of course not
what's what's the political climate at
the time
who's the republican challenger is it
newsom versus desantis is it newsman
versus trump is it newsome versus nikki
haley there's no way to say newsome
would win
but the idea that the california numbers
prove newsom's not popular now give me a
break knew someone with really good
numbers in 2018 and he survived the
recall with the same exact numbers i
mean even that i believe that in a
gubernatorial race and we will see in
november newsom may win with even bigger
numbers if the recall went so poorly for
those who wanted to remove him it's hard
to imagine that uh he's going to not do
well in november but we will see i don't
see it as a problem whatsoever on the
bonus show today
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
and other lawmakers were arrested for
protesting at the supreme court there
are people fixating on aoc pretending to
be handcuffed
and then raising a fist i'm going to
talk about that and tell you about
whether that's even really the main part
of the story hint it's not secondly the
doctor who provided the abortion to the
10 year old girl who had to go from ohio
to indiana is now suing the attorney
general of indiana for defamation we
will talk about what's going on there
and third
inflation is real and it's a problem for
many people and we've been talking about
it but economists are now getting wise
to the fact that inflation is providing
cover for price fixing not just price
gouging price gouging is one thing price
fixing this is price collusion is
another way to put it
and we're going to talk about that on
the bonus show as well
three things for you to do number one
sign up as a member at joinpacman.com
you can use the coupon code obama
to get a discount you will get instant
access to the bonus show as well as the
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show number two
make sure you're subscribed to our
second youtube channel pacman live
because on tuesday we'll be doing our
next viewer town hall
everyone is welcome to call in but you
will only be able to watch the town hall
on the pacman live youtube channel and
number three
don't send me any hate messages those
are the instructions thank you see
everybody either on the bonus show or
tomorrow on our next episode
you